but no wait how how important is love in
a marriage then because i think we can
draw a direct comparison between i think
i think love is the most important thing
personally sorry you think love's the
most important thing so then why
marriage is lasting then because if more
people if more women now marry for love
i am
logically more marriages will last
longer whether it's prior they're not
marrying for love it was out of
necessity or
well i think there was a still a mixture
of both you have to remember that
obviously for example if you had a small
town most people did grow up in small
towns back in the day there was cities
weren't as big as they are now right um
so you used to find that
the the people who
would be you know let's just betroth or
whatever they were um
yeah they may have actually had
um
may have met each other and had a
flirtation or whatever so there was
definitely love that could have been
built from that right it's totally
different from if if
a family's
shipping their daughter off to someone
from thousands of miles away or
something i don't know and i think that
happens too but
um
i i i think the the problem is is that
just because there's no love in a
marriage doesn't make it a good or
unhappy i'm not saying necessarily
there's no love i'm just saying there's
a direct comparison between
old school marriages and modern
marriages arguably modern marriages have
more love but
modern marriages don't last anymore and
the main reason for them not lasting is
women in initiating divorces for various
reasons yeah well obviously various
reasons and i i think it's a it's one of
those things that
unfortunately we'd like to say it was
women's fault for divorce because you
know
yeah well you say it's their fault but
they don't want initiating divorces yeah
but the initiation doesn't doesn't
doesn't 80 to 90 of the time doesn't
stop
what's brought them to that point how do
we know
how their marriage has been yeah to push
them right
to say i don't want to be because
because because cheating statistics are
similar so so men and women yes between
between men and women
yeah but so so they're getting equally
become more similar
and same 20 years ago right but we're in
2022 now and so that's why he's saying
it's their fault because again cheating
statistics are similar right even even
abuse like actually men in most abusive
relationships people are abusing each
other so it's not one-sided they're both
abusive towards each other and the
majority of one-sided abuse it's
actually more women are one-sidedly
abusive to men than men are to women
so that means like they're not hitting
back
so it's one-sided so sorry sorry wait
can you
okay so the majority of abusive
situations are mutually abusive so that
means the man's hitting the woman the
woman's hitting the man
so that that's the majority of abuse
cases i'm sorry where did you get that
statistic from so it's actually a
feminist actually went in and did the
research on this so she was an
ex-feminist she did a whole documentary
basically looking into the men's rights
movement and then she came across so
that that data set comes from that
documentary okay
by the way my
but i have a small group of best friends
every single one of them has been an
abusive relationship i'm telling you
we only fight back when we have to we
are scared
but but here is there is not one part of
me that believes that
all
most most abusive relationships
one-sided abuse i didn't say i didn't
say mutually i said one-sided abuse i
thought you i thought you just said no
so i said most abusive relationships
they're abusing each other yeah which is
mutually yes yes well i don't believe
that okay well
i don't i don't believe that's true i i
don't know what study this woman did but
it doesn't sound true to me especially
with my experiences my friends
experiences it just doesn't ring true
well i mean we could go over the data
later if you want but
like it's it's from a reputable source
so so what i'm saying though is
basically
if if the cheating stats are similar the
if we look at the abuse statistics women
are more abusive towards men than men
are towards women because think about it
women can get away with it more
that's why i believe it because if you
take away the consequences for someone
they're going to do it more i'm not
saying that women like like men and
women are equally capable of abuse but
women don't always go to jail for it i
mean look at what happened in miami
with that that only fans model she
killed her boyfriend
and she's walking free right now if the
roles were reversed it wouldn't happen
so if you take away the consequences in
a society they're going to do it more
like to me to me that makes sense
so
it that's why he's saying that it's
the woman's fault because
we both have problems but the women is
the one leaving
[Music]
can i um just add something to that so
when you said there's um
you said the stats for marriages with
parental
guidance basically last longer right
yep okay so with that don't you think
marriage is like that anyway so let's
just say arrange marriage or things like
that usually involve let's say religion
a cultural aspect things like that you
wouldn't just out of your own back if
you have no none of that like cultural
religion you wouldn't be like yeah mum
go find me a husband like i don't i
don't think you would so don't you think
because of that they last longer because
one both of you because you're both
families are involved you're not going
to speak out um fear of being judged
um also probably
speaking out or going your separate ways
is
looked bad upon
there's so many other reasons hence the
fact the stats might show that but i'm
saying there's so many aspects as to why
women won't leave that kind of situation
so i i agree with you i do think part of
it is there was less shame back then in
doing it i also i also agree that
there's religious
reasons that people stay but the point
is when there's a family the kids are
more important than you
so it's about duty over love
this is where they stay like several
friends in relationships that their
parents put them in speaking to them
sorry and the lady is she's quite a bit
older than me she has two kids she loves
her husband she's not in love with her
husband
and she was put together with him and
she's going through something right now
where she doesn't know what to do she
doesn't know where to leave and go find
a new life because she's obviously she's
happy she has kids and she has a partner
but they were put together and it's not
that she's in love with him she's just
been told this is what you should be
doing so she's staying for the children
because she knows it's the right thing
this this is what scares men is they can
put a lifetime of resources into a woman
and she'll leave because she doesn't
feel like she's in love anymore because
feelings come and go like this is why
men don't want to get married but i
don't think she was ever in love to
begin with she was put into that
situation she was never in love with
this man she had children with this man
because her parents told her she should
so she has love for him she's he's the
father of her kids but she's not in love
with how old is she she's
38 i'd say a couple years older than me
38 and she doesn't know whether she
wants to stay or go no well no
how old are the kids they're big they're
grown they're great they're grown kids
but she feels like if she walks away now
because she's put together the family
the family are going to look down on her
right well i mean i think there should
be shame and divorce
yeah bring back shame
i mean
i think it depends on the city yeah
not really
if you put yourself in the situation
yeah but if you're fortunate how old was
she she was young she was 15. she got
married at 15. yeah i'll give her a pass
fifteen she's kind of young that's what
i mean a lot of arranged marriages are
that yeah they are not not in 2022 the
average age of first marriage is 27 and
28 and even back then it was over the
age of 18. but sorry are we not talking
about very
western statistics here
right but so so on isn't well that's why
we're talking about the west like this
conversation is has feminism destroyed
marriage right but the problem yeah but
the problem with that is that is that
the reality of it is that with the
cultural um clashes in the uk right now
we don't have just a if you say oh
people are getting married at a certain